so there is a suicide machine in
switzerland that's currently being
tested and in the next few years
people are projecting that it's going to
be
like a viable option for people who want
to do assisted suicide it's pretty lit
if you want to kill yourself because you
can just wheel this to like say malibu
and stare at the beach you jump in it
just fills it with gas and you fall
asleep you die in your sleep oh wow you
basically fall asleep and then the
machine slowly starts to take the oxygen
out of the air and you just die
peacefully is what the uh of no but you
have no oxygen so you fall asleep and
then you become oxygen deprived after
within the next few minutes wasn't there
a doctor that was a sister
kevorkian dr kevorkian it provides a
sense of occasion by its looks it looks
good it's a thing i'd like to get into
but since uh stylish
concept four years ago it's been met
with varying degrees of bewilderment
some critics arguing that appearance is
one of its biggest problems
keep scrolling down chen
um
almost a luxury car like design
glamorizes suicide i get that
can lead to more people dying the real
worry the machine likes to clarify
suicide makes it easier for people who
are vulnerable and mentally ill yeah i
agree
yeah
yeah make it very odd to commit yeah
yeah you should probably talk to
professionals
um but if you are ready to go like say
you have like stage five cancers like go
time you're like [ __ ] this
yeah if you get like an approval from a
doctor
or some [ __ ]
it's a decent option there's a woman who
got on a cruise and she left a whole
diary about how she was going to wait
till she got to the deepest part of the
ocean and she had a backpack and
everything and she wrote a little rock
yep she
waits and she wrote a whole diary of it
and she waited till they got to the
deepest part of the ocean and she just
jumped off the cruise with her with this
backpack and that's how she died
and
my phone was one of the police officers
who um
who investigated it and it was just
fascinating like it was just this whole
diary that she left wow but it's in the
diary but i was thinking about like
mentally ill you know just somebody who
was talking about going to the next
dimension and how she was very peaceful
and but she was clearly there was just
such a premeditated way of doing it but
i don't know jumping off into the water
at nighttime it's all right
backpack and then you think it's part of
the ocean and you think you're just
gonna float to the bottom you're gonna
change the sharky shark goes oh yeah oh
oh what's up yeah and then you die by
suicide by sharks yeah that's a
miserable way to go or you just die by
by not breathing by you're just being
taken to the bottom of the ocean the icy
cold how scary that is